[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another Fandango indie movie guide I
am still recovering from that crazy
Afghan night but let's reset the clock
because we've got another year to find
the next best picture winner and of
course it's going to come from the world
of mb so let's get into what you can see
in theaters and at home this week
starting with I don't feel at home in
this world anymore it's a really long
title but this is a movie that is worth
watching available on netflix right now
it's directed by makin blair he's an
actor who starred in Jeremy fournier's
films like blue ruin and green room and
if you know those movies if you know the
work of Jeremy Sonnier then this film
will remind you a lot of that but with
much more humor it says the brilliant
melanie lynskey as roof she is fed up
with the jerks of everyday life people
who cut you off on the line in the fifth
market or Drive big trucks which few
exhaust so won't you come time when she
finds that her house has been robbed she
decides she's had enough and she wants
to do something about it track down all
her stuff and she enlists the help of
her very strange neighbor who's played
by Elijah Wood I can get these nice you
think it is not good I'm glad your
change leads to makes it such a quirky
dynamic duo they have great chemistry
together and overall I love the tone of
the movie it shifts quite wildly between
being thrilling and scary intense to
being very very funny and that is a hard
thing to do it will make you laugh it's
beautifully shot it's really fun time so
definitely check out I don't feel at
home in this world anymore on netflix
not letting you shoot anyone
anyone anywhere else into theaters now
there's a really interesting documentary
out this week called my Scientology
movie by the brilliant Louis through he
is someone who is always going into
these strange worlds and learning about
different groups here he tries to do it
with Scientology the thing with
Scientology is that it's very closed off
it's very private you can't really get
into this world but so much secrecy
about what happens so many illegal
dramas with people who leave the church
and want to speak out about it so Louis
wasn't able to get into the church you
need to guard your Christmas guarding
the place okay we have apartment right
here behind you have their attention why
are they doing this not like easy church
did you think of instead he talks to
ex-judge members and then he does
something very interesting where he cast
actors as leaders from Scientology to
kind of play out what would happen in
Scientology very interesting and I'm
sure it's going to rub some people the
wrong way because it's not technically a
documentary that's got these recreations
I thought it was so funny and
fascinating Louis through is one of the
best documentarians working today so
check out my Scientology movie which is
out in limited theaters this weekend
tell him Tommy well you're storming off
helps him well you told him to stop tell
him to stop you told him to stop and
I'll tell him to stop
thanks guys two other films out in
theaters that I want to get too quickly
the first one is called cat fight it's
does an H and Sandra oh and like the
title suggests is about an epic cat
fight these two women who are very
opposite from each other they used to go
to college together they meet up again
get drunk have a big fight and then one
of them ends up in a coma mr. salt my
name is dr. Jones you've been in a coma
for two years what the whole film really
is an allegory for where we are in the
world today with a lot of war and a lot
of hatred similar to I don't feel at
home in this world anymore and catfights
see characters have just had enough but
the whole film is very absurd I had a
fun time watching it you can see cat
fights in limited theaters this weekend
[Music]
and the last film i want to get to is
the last word starring shirley maclaine
and amanda seyfried the sort of leaving
my obituary to chance is completely
unusable to me well I am the obituary
writer so when the time comes I will be
writing your obituary I want you to
write it now so it was a little bit
predictable but it's a very easy watch
the reason why I liked it was because of
showing the claim I mean she's one of my
favorite actresses around I watched the
apartment at least twice a year she's so
wonderful at portraying these broken
characters and CS she lends a whole
Joseph's compassion through her very
tough rough character she really is the
center of the movie so you can see the
last word in limited theaters this
weekend arias your piece of work I am
Who I am
recapping if you're at home and see I
don't feel at home in this world anymore
if you want to go to the theater you've
got my Scientology movie we've got cat
fights or the last word let me know in
the comments below what you thought
about the Oscars I mean why are the
great things that came out of it was the
display of love between my two favorite
movies lala land and moonlight you can
tell that they both really respect each
other a lot so in a weird way they both
got their moment in the Sun so that's a
good way to look at it I guess I'm
Malaysia malaria and he'll see you next
week bye